Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At New Balance, we believe if you run, you're a a runner however you choose to do it because when you're not worried about doing things the right way you're free to discover your way and that's what running's all about
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在 New Balance，我们坚信只要你跑步，你就是个跑者，无论你选择以何种方式因为当你不再担心用“正确”的方式做事时你就能自由地去探索属于你的方式这正是跑步的真谛
run your way at newbalance.com slash running. You and I have a rendezvous with destiny. We'll preserve for our children this, the last best hope of man on earth, or we'll sentence them to take the last step into a thousand years of darkness. We will keep in mind and remember that Barry Goldwater has faith in us. He has faith that you and I have the ability and the dignity and the right to make our own decisions and determine our own destiny.
在 newbalance.com 斜杠 running，跑出你的专属风格。你我与命运有个约会。我们要为子孙后代守护这全人类在地球上的最后且最好的希望，否则我们将判处他们迈出走向千年黑暗的最后一步。我们要牢记并铭记，巴里·戈德华特对我们充满信心。他坚信你我都有能力、有尊严、有权利做出自己的决定并决定我们自己的命运。
Thank you very much. That, Dominic, was, of course, Ronald Reagan giving what I think, and you would be the person who'd know this because you've actually taught this. Isn't this known as the speech? The speech. Yes, it is. Given in 1964. For Barry Goldwater, the Republican nominee The speech. Yes, it is. Given in 1964 for Barry Goldwater, the Republican nominee for president. So this was the moment that really catapulted Reagan onto the political stage.
非常感谢。多米尼克，那当然是罗纳德·里根发表的演讲，依我之见——而你最清楚不过了，因为你真的教过这个。这不就是被称为“那场演讲”的演讲吗？“那场演讲”。是的，正是。发表于1964年。为了巴里·戈德华特，共和党总统“那场演讲”。是的，正是。发表于1964年，支持共和党总统候选人巴里·戈德华特。所以，正是这个时刻，真正将里根推上了政治舞台。
I mean, this speech was an absolute... I mean, Goldwater went down to a terrible defeat, but is now often seen as the sort of herald of Reagan's brand of conservatism. But it was this speech that brought Reagan to the attention of a lot of rich businessmen in California that basically won him indirectly the governorship of California and set him on the path to the presidency. And you delivered that, Tom, with all the earnestness. Well, I mean, in so many ways, he was an old ham. And so are you.
我的意思是，这场演讲绝对是一场……我的意思是，戈德华特遭遇了惨败，但现在人们通常认为这是里根式保守主义的某种先声。正是这场演讲让里根引起了加州许多富有商人的注意，这基本上间接地为他赢得了加州州长之位，并让他踏上了通往总统宝座的道路。汤姆，你把那段话念得真是字字铿锵、充满诚意。好吧，我的意思是，从很多方面来说，他就是一个老戏骨。你也是。
Yeah. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. So I identify with that. Yeah. So we left Reagan, his acting career in the doldrums. And I'd always kind of wondered basically how he got from his acting career to becoming governor of California. Yeah. And basically this episode is all about explaining how and why but at the
是的。对。是啊。是啊。所以我对此很有共鸣。是啊。所以我们说到里根，他当时的演艺事业正处于低谷。我其实一直有点好奇，他是怎么从演艺事业过渡到成为加州州长的。对。基本上这期节目就是要解释如何以及为什么，但在
end of the last episode we lifted on a particular cliffhanger which was um that he'd got divorced from Jane Wyman yeah who basically divorced him because she fed up with him endlessly going on about all the stuff he'd read in the reader's digest yes um and he then played the town with a number of ladies yeah who he called his cocker spaniels. Some of them, Tom, were quite young. Well. So there's some gossip, God, I must at some point says, we never thought we'd say this, but Ronnie Reagan is playing the wolf or something like that.
上一集的结尾，我们留下了一个悬念，那就是——嗯，他和简·怀曼离婚了，是的，简·怀曼之所以和他离婚，是因为她受够了他没完没了地唠叨他在《读者文摘》上读到的那些东西，是的——随后他开始在镇上和好几位女士交往，是的，他管这些女士叫他的“可卡犬”。汤姆，其中有些女士还挺年轻的。好吧。所以这里有些八卦，天哪，我必须在某个时候说，我们从没想过我们会说这话：罗尼·里根现在在扮演情圣什么的。
Isn't that the expression they use? The old dog. There's life in the old dog, yeah. Yeah. But the thing is, he's almost, what is he? He's almost 40. And he doesn't really like it does he because he's he's he's naturally he he likes to settle down with a good woman exactly but he's sort of playing the field he has a lot of girlfriends
这不是他们用的那个词吗？老当益壮。老骥伏枥，志在千里，是的。是的。但问题是，他快要，他多大了？他快40岁了。而且他其实并不太喜欢这种生活，对吧？因为他天生，他喜欢和一位好女性安定下来，确切地说，但他现在有点在花丛中流连，有很多女朋友。
oh a young actress called piper lorry who i think was 18 and then wrote a memoir in the 1980s saying so that's very leonardo dicaprio very leonardo dicaprio behavior saying this was the first encounter she'd had with a man of any kind and reagan old enough to be her father and was he nice uh did you like him or did you think he was a perv or what i don't think she was i don't think she went into kind of immense detail about the encounter um i don't think she was presenting him in a terribly bad light right i think now now you know people are very down on leonardo dicaprio about his uh yes dating patterns aren't they yes um but reagan himself was you're right it wasn't really him he wasn't a gigolo no he he was he was playing the field but it didn't come naturally should we say yeah actually that made him the perfect you know somebody is eyeing him up and that is nancy nancy
哦，一个叫派珀·劳瑞的年轻女演员，我记得当时她18岁，后来在20世纪80年代写了一本回忆录说——这太莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥了，太莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥式的行为了——说这是她第一次跟任何类型的男人有接触，而里根的年纪当她父亲都够了，他人好吗？呃，你喜欢他吗？还是觉得他是个色狼什么的？我觉得她并没有，我觉得她没有对这次接触进行特别详尽的描述，呃，我不觉得她是在把他描绘成一个极其糟糕的形象。对。我觉得现在，现在你知道人们对莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥的呃，是的，约会模式很有意见，不是吗？是的，呃，但里根自己，你说得对，其实那不是真正的他，他不是个舞男，不，他，他在花丛中流连，但这并不是他的天性，我们可以这么说，是的。事实上，这让他成为了完美的人——有人在暗中物色他，那就是南希，南希
davis so nancy she had a gorgeous mother have you seen the photo of her edith yeah yeah absolutely stunning yeah because so often you know you you see photographs of women who are described as famous beauties yeah in in period photos and they don't do men tom we're very yeah no but i'm because since we're on the subject of nancy's mother yeah um but nancy's mother, I mean, fabulous. Yes. She's a very appealing sounding person, Edith Luggett. Yes.
戴维斯。所以南希，她有一位极其美貌的母亲，你看过她母亲伊迪丝的照片吗？对，对，绝对惊艳。因为很多时候，你知道，你会看到那些被称为“著名美女”的女性照片，在老照片里，她们并没有——汤姆，我们真的很——不，但我是说，既然我们聊到南希的母亲，是的，但南希的母亲，我的天，太棒了。是的。伊迪丝·勒盖特听上去是个非常有魅力的人。是的。
She goes around doing her kind of stage shows and singing and she's a great figure on the stage. And she has a – she marries a surgeon. She marries a surgeon called Loyal Davis. Yeah. So we mentioned at the end of the last episode, the names in the next sequence of Reagan's story are wholly improbable. I mean, if you read them in a novel, you wouldn't believe them.
她四处进行某种舞台表演和唱歌，是舞台上一个了不起的人物。她有一个——她嫁给了一位外科医生。她嫁给了一位名叫洛ayal·戴维斯的外科医生。是的。所以我们在上一集结尾提到过，里根故事中接下来的这一连串名字简直匪夷所思。我的意思是，如果你在小说里读到它们，你都不会相信。
No. So Loyal Davis. Loyal Davis. And actually, Nancy is not Loyal Davis's daughter, but she adopts Loyal Davis's name, doesn't she? She calls herself debutante. She's from a very different background from Dutch Reagan, growing up in his fairly impecunious small towns in the Midwest. She is a debutante in Chicago, and she goes to Smith College, one of the Seven Sisters, this very fancy women's college. And in her senior class, do you know the part she played in the senior class play? Titania.
没错。所以是洛ayal·戴维斯。洛ayal·戴维斯。而且实际上，南希并不是洛ayal·戴维斯的亲生女儿，但她采用了洛ayal·戴维斯的姓氏，对吧？她自称是社交名媛。她的背景和“荷兰人”里根截然不同，里根是在中西部那些较为贫困的小镇长大的。她是芝加哥的一名社交名媛，就读于“七姐妹”学院之一的史密斯学院，这是一所非常高档的女子学院。在她大四那年，你知道她在毕业戏剧里扮演什么角色吗？泰坦妮娅。
No, she played the wife of a president of the United States. Did she? Yeah. An imaginary president or a real one? An imaginary president, I think. Right. Okay. I don't know. I don't know. I didn't dig down that deep. Okay.
不，她扮演的是美国总统的夫人。是吗？对。一个虚构的总统还是一个真实的？我想是个虚构的总统吧。对。好吧。我不知道。我不知道。我没有挖得那么深。好吧。
And she wants to be an actress, doesn't she? Like her mum, because her mum's very famous. Yeah, but she's nowhere near as good. I mean, she's nowhere near as good as her mum. her mum's very famous yeah but she's nowhere near as good i mean she's nowhere near as good as her mum or indeed she's not as good a performer as ronald reagan is so she goes to hollywood and she gets in with uh the guy who's in charge of casting at mgm he's called benny thau who is regarded he is regarded he is the sultan of the casting couch is he yeah i'm not sure the sultan is the word i was looking for but he is the he's the king of the casting couch of the casting couch. Is he? Yeah. I'm not sure the Sultan is the word I was looking for, but he is the, he's the king of the casting couch. Khan of the casting couch.
她想成为一名演员，对吧？就像她妈妈一样，因为她妈妈非常有名。对，但她差得远呢。我的意思是，她根本比不上她妈妈。她妈妈非常有名，是的，但她差得远呢。我的意思是，她根本比不上她妈妈，或者说，她的表演水平确实不如罗纳德·里根。所以她去了好莱坞，搭上了米高梅负责选角的那个人，他叫本尼·托乌，被认为——他被认为是——她是选角榻上的苏丹吗？是吗？呃，我不确定“苏丹”是不是我想找的词，但他确实是，他是选角榻之王，是选角榻之王。是吗？呃，我不确定“苏丹”是不是我想找的词，但他确实是，他是选角榻之王。选角榻的可汗。
Khan of the casting couch. The great Khan of the casting couch. Okay. Okay. Here's the great Khan. He's the despot of the casting couch. And, um,
选角榻的可汗。选角榻的伟大的可汗。好吧。好吧。这位就是伟大的可汗。他是选角榻的独裁者。然后呢，
it was later very ungallantly said of Nancy that she had basically slept her way to a contract. Um, I don't know whether that's true or not. There's definitely a perception of her from the very beginning that she's incredibly ambitious and she's a bit of a woman on the make. And she obviously identifies Ron Reagan in his capacity as the head of the Screen Actors Guild because she has accidentally
后来人们对南希做出了很不绅士的评价，说她基本上是靠一路睡才拿到合同的。呃，我不知道这是真是假。从一开始，人们就普遍认为她极其野心勃勃，而且有点借上位往上爬的女人那种调调。而且她显然认出了罗恩·里根的身份，因为他是演艺工会的主席，因为她不小心
been put on not a blacklist but a kind of a grey list as people with kind of lefty sympathies which she absolutely doesn't and uh she contacts him and says please take my make you know use your influence to get my name off this list and they end up going for dinner and you know one thing leads to another and she unlike jane wyman loves listening to ronang on. About the Reeds Digest. All that kind of stuff. Yeah. And she just kind of gazes up at him adoringly, doesn't she?
被列入的不是黑名单，而是一种灰名单，上面都是有左翼同情倾向的人，而她根本没有这种倾向，呃，她联系了他，说请帮个忙，你知道，用你的影响力把我的名字从这个名单上划掉。最后他们一起去吃晚饭，你知道，事情就这样顺理成章地发展下去了。而且她与简·怀曼不同，她非常喜欢听罗恩唠叨。关于《读者文摘》的事。所有诸如此类的事情。而且她就那样崇拜地仰望着他，不是吗？
I think she absolutely does. She absolutely does. So she puts pressure on him, I think, to get married. She's pregnant when they get married. So that's February 1952. She falls pregnant and they get married in March. And really interesting and a real surprise for me is that before they choose the date, they consult an astrologer, Carol Reiter, the astrologer to the stars.
我想她绝对是这样的。绝对是的。所以我想是她在施加压力，催促他结婚。他们结婚时她已经怀孕了。所以那是1952年2月。她怀孕了，然后他们在3月结婚。而非常有趣、让我大吃一惊的是，在他们选择日期之前，他们咨询了一位占星家卡罗尔·雷特，也就是明星们的占星家。
And it's Reagan who pushes that. Yes. So everyone thinks that Nancy is kind of enthralled by astrology. But actually, she embraces it because Ronald Reagan is already into astrology, as a lot of Hollywood stars are in the 50s. You know that vogue, everyone now has a therapist, don't they, in Hollywood? Well, everyone had meant to see the astrologer in those days. I mean, maybe they were getting into therapy as well. So wasn't Nancy into it before she met Reagan?
是里根力主这么做的。是的。所以每个人都以为是南希对占星术着迷。但实际上，她之所以接受它，是因为罗纳德·里根早就迷上了占星术，就像许多50年代的好莱坞明星一样。你知道那种风潮，现在好莱坞每个人都有个心理医生，对吧？嗯，那时候每个人都得去看占星家。我是说，也许他们当时也开始接触心理治疗了。所以难道不是在遇到里根之前南希就迷上这个了吗？
I'm not sure that she was. I mean, all the stuff about the astrology, i had sort of imagined was cooked up i'd always thought it was exaggerated by kitty kelly and um i mean don regan who was regan's chief of staff in the mid 80s he said oh nancy plans everything with her astrologer and i sort of thought oh that's just gossip and sour grapes but it's absolutely not i mean the astrology they take they take it terribly seriously. They consult astrologers when they're kind of putting on their trousers or something. So, yeah, they get married. But in some ways, Reagan looks like a bad investment from her point of view because his film career is pretty much dead by this point, 1952. There's no call for his kind of – I mean, he's a bit old.
我不确定她之前是不是这样。我是说，关于占星术的那些事，我以前一直以为是编造的，我总觉得是被基蒂·凯利夸大了，而且——我是说，唐·里根，他80年代中期担任里根的白宫办公厅主任，他说过：“哦，南希所有的计划都是跟她的占星师商量着来的。”我当时还想，这不过是八卦和吃不到葡萄说葡萄酸罢了。但绝对不是这样——我是说，占星术，他们对待占星术简直严肃得无以复加。他们连穿裤子之类的事都要去请教占星师。所以，是的，他们结婚了。但从某些方面来看，从南希的角度来看，里根就像一笔糟糕的投资，因为到1952年这个时间点，他的电影事业基本上已经死了。根本没有人找他演那种——我是说，他有点老了。
He's in his 40s. He's not playing the hero's best friend anymore. Is this when he goes to Vegas? He does go to Vegas and he hates it. He absolutely hates it. Going to Vegas and sort of doing a turn. Because it's seen as a mark of failure because he's, he's kind of hosting cabaret shows.
他已经四十多岁了。他不再适合演英雄的好朋友了。这就是他去拉斯维加斯的时候吗？他的确去了拉斯维加斯，而且恨透了那里。他简直恨透了。去拉斯维加斯客串演出。因为那被视为失败的标志，他在那里主持歌舞表演。
Exactly. He does a two week stint. I think it is. And he really doesn't like it at all. It really is. He thinks it's tawdry. He thinks it's humiliating. And it's at this point, or pretty much at this point,
确切地说。他在那里干了两周。我想是的。而且他真的非常讨厌那段经历。千真万确。他觉得那里俗不可耐。他觉得这是一种羞辱。也正是在这个时候，或者差不多就是在这个时候，
that he is approached. In his capacity at the Screen Actors Guild, he had done a deal to allow his own agency, MCA, to move into TV production. Previously, agencies were not allowed to get involved with TV production. He broke us a deal. And about a year or so later, two years later, MCA come to him.
他迎来了转机。凭借他在演艺工会的身份，他曾达成一项协议，允许他自己的经纪公司MCA进军电视制作领域。此前，经纪公司是不被允许涉足电视制作的。他打破了这个禁例。大约一年或一年多、两年后，MCA找到了他。
This guy called Taft Schreiber comes to him and says, we've had an offer for you, and I think this is perfect. So General Electric are sponsoring a program called General Electric Theatre. It's been running off and on, but they really want to invest in it. They want to make it a weekly thing, and they need a host. So basically, MCA clients will appear on TV. It's an anthology. They'll appear in a series of plays.
一个叫塔夫特·施赖伯的家伙来找他说，我们手头有个提议，我觉得对你来说简直完美。通用电气正在赞助一档名为《通用电气剧场》的节目。这个节目断断续续地播过，但他们现在真的想加大投资。他们想把它变成一个周播节目，并且需要一个主持人。基本上，MCA的签约艺人都会上电视。这是一部选集剧。他们会出演一系列的独幕剧。
And we think it will be a ratings topper, be a massive hit, and General Electric are going to put in a lot of money. We need a host to do a two-minute introduction to give it a sense of coherence. But also the host must be a goodwill ambassador for General Electric. So there'll be a lot of work touring General Electric plants, giving speeches, meeting the workers,
我们认为这会成为收视冠军，会大获成功，通用电气将投入大量资金。我们需要一个主持人来做两分钟的开场白，以保持节目的连贯性。但同时，这位主持人还必须是通用电气的亲善大使。所以会有大量的工作，包括巡视通用电气的工厂、发表演讲、会见工人们，
being the kind of face of General Electric. You see, when I read about this, I had not understood that 30 Rock, the Tina Fey sitcom, about a comedy show. And it's all owned by General Electric. And I never understood what General Electric were doing involved in a kind of comedy show. But now I understand. It's obviously a kind of long running tradition in America.
成为通用电气的某种门面。你看，当我读到这段历史时，我以前并不明白蒂娜·菲的那部情景喜剧《我本坚强》（30 Rock）里演的是一个喜剧节目。而且它整个都归通用电气所有。我从来搞不懂通用电气怎么会跟某种喜剧节目扯上关系。但现在我明白了。这显然是美国一种历史悠久的传统。
Yes. So the firm would sponsor the show if the firm walked away the show ends that's where you know the money for the show is coming from so general electric are offering to pay reagan 125 000 a year that's the equivalent of three million dollars a year today i would say and general electric have a really really sort of ruthless and cunning attitude towards advertising and getting their message across. So you're talking about people having excellent names. The man running their ad account is called Earl Dunkel.
是的。因此，如果这家公司撤资，节目就会停播，这就是节目资金的来源，所以通用电气提出每年付给里根12.5万美元，我得说，这相当于今天的每年300万美元。而且通用电气对待广告以及如何传达他们的商业信息，有着非常非常冷酷和精明的态度。说到这个，那些人的名字都起得极好。负责他们广告业务的人叫厄尔·邓克尔。
But the real guiding spirit of man who's in charge of their labor relations is Lemuel Boulware. Yes. And Boulware-ism, as it's called, involves basically you use your own workers as the advert for your company. You persuade your own workers of the virtue of your company. So in other words, bulwurism was you persuade your workers that government intervention and regulation have gone too far, that free enterprise is the American way, free market, all this stuff, anti-communism and low taxes. And so by this time, Reagan is buying into this.
但真正指引精神、负责劳资关系的灵魂人物是莱穆尔·鲍尔威尔。是的。而所谓的“鲍尔威尔主义”，基本上就是把你的工人们当作你公司的活广告。你让自己的工人们信服你公司的美德。换句话说，鲍尔威尔主义就是说服你的工人们相信：政府的干预和监管已经过头了，自由企业才是美国的康庄大道，自由市场，诸如此类，反共产主义和低税收。所以到了这个时候，里根已经深信不疑了。
Oh, yes. 1952 is the first time he votes Republican, right? Eisenhower, yeah. And he felt a little bit bad about it because his father had always been such a keen Democrat. And he actually says at the time, there are things about Adlai Stevenson, the Democratic candidate that I quite like. However, it sort of makes sense that Reagan is moving rightwards. He is rich. All his friends in Hollywood, the people that he hangs out with, as we were saying before, they're quite right-wing. Nancy is quite right-wing. But also, he's reading. As you said, the Reader's Digest, he's also become absolutely addicted to a
哦，是的。1952年是他第一次投票给共和党，对吧？艾森豪威尔，是的。而且他当时觉得有点内疚，因为他父亲一直是个坚定的民主党人。他当时甚至说过，阿德莱·史蒂芬森（民主党候选人）身上有些地方我还是挺喜欢的。然而，里根向右转也是顺理成章的。他很有钱。他在好莱坞的所有朋友、他平日交往的人，正如我们之前所说，都相当右翼。南希也相当右翼。而且他在阅读。正如你所说，除了《读者文摘》，他还变得对一本
periodical called Human Events, which is, again, very, very firmly right-wing. So he's being radicalized by mid-market magazines. Yes, he actually is. And when he goes to General Electric, that radicalizes him further. And he, by the way, the interesting thing is not the two-minute introductions to the episodes, it's the tours, because he turns out to be absolutely brilliant at it. He will go to the episodes it's the tours because he turns out to be absolutely brilliant at it he will go to the plant there is a wonderful description of this in um bob spitz bob spitz bob spitz but also other writers so gary wills wrote about this in his book reagan's
名为《人间世事》（Human Events）的期刊极其着迷，而这本书同样非常非常坚定地站在右翼立场。所以他是被大众市场杂志给“激进化”了。是的，他确实如此。当他去到通用电气时，这进一步加剧了他的激进化。而且，顺便说一句，有趣的地方不在于每集那两分钟的开场白，而是那些巡回演讲，因为事实证明他在这一行简直天赋异禀。他会去到——剧集的开场白不是重点，巡回演讲才是，因为事实证明他在这一行简直天赋异禀。他会去到工厂，在
america innocence at home in the 80s the general electorate was the key to reagan as bob spitz describes it reagan goes into the plant and at first people are sort of staring at him. And his technique is he will usually talk to the women because they're delighted to see a Hollywood matinee idol, a film star. And the men are a little bit suspicious. And then after he's talked to the women and they've all sort of gushed over him, he then goes over to the men and he makes a few jokes. He tells them a few jokes about the women often. And he puts the men at their ease and very, very quickly they get into kind of banter and gossip and he tells Hollywood stories. He's one of the boys. He has this film style glamour, of course, he's tanned and he's tall and whatnot, but he has such an affable down to earth manner. He's brilliant at putting people
鲍勃·斯皮茨（Bob Spitz）的书里有对这段经历的精彩描述——鲍勃·斯皮茨，鲍勃·斯皮茨——不过其他作家也写过，比如加里·威尔斯在80年代的著作《里根的美国：家园的纯真》（Reagan's America: Innocents at Home）中就写过，通用电气才是里根的关键所在。正如鲍勃·斯皮茨所描述的那样，里根走进工厂，起初人们只是盯着他看。他的策略通常是先和女工们聊天，因为她们很高兴能见到好莱坞的日间场偶像、电影明星。而男人们则有点怀疑。然后，在和女工们聊完、她们都对里根赞不绝口之后，他就会走向男人们，开几个玩笑。他经常会讲几个关于女工的玩笑。他让男人们放松下来，很快，他们就能开始打趣、八卦，他还会讲好莱坞的故事。他就像是他们中的一员。他当然带着那种电影明星般的魅力，晒得黝黑，身材高大之类，但他有着极其随和、接地气的风度。他特别擅长让别人
at their ease. He's one of the guys. He's absolutely one of the boys. Absolutely. And then as part of this, he gives after dinner speeches. So General Electric start to organize. He'll talk to the Rotary Club or the Chamber of Commerce or, or whatever. And the,
放松下来。他就是这群人中的一员。绝对是他们中的一员。完全如此。作为其中一部分，他还要发表餐后演讲。于是通用电气开始组织这些活动。他会去对扶轮社、商会或者其他什么机构发表演讲。而且，
and the speeches that he gives are, he'll start with some jokes and some Hollywood anecdotes and be self-deprecating. And then he'll start talking a jokes and some Hollywood anecdotes and be self-deprecating. And then he'll start talking a little bit about politics, not in an excessively partisan way. So in other words, if you're a Democrat, you can still enjoy it. But he'll say things that lots of people kind of agree with in a slightly kind of golf clubby, men at the bar kind of way. He'll say, we pay a lot of taxes and what do we get for them? You know, those people in Washington, they're all the same. Don't you just love our country
他发表的演讲，通常会从一些笑话和好莱坞轶事开始，表现得十分自谦。然后他会开始谈论一点政治，但不会显得过于党派化。换句话说，如果你是个民主党人，你依然能听得津津有味。但他会以一种略带高尔夫俱乐部聊天、酒吧闲谈般的口吻，说出许多人都会认同的话。他会说：“我们交了那么多税，到底换回了什么？你知道的，华盛顿的那帮人，全都是一个德行。难道你不爱我们的国家，
and you hate people running it down? Communism, we've got to stand up to that. You know, he'll come out with all this sort of stuff. Most people will just nod and say, this is great. And what Reagan does that is brilliant, and he gets this from Reader's Digest and whatnot, is he wraps it up in parables and little stories. His increasingly right-wing convictions, are they any more sophisticated than, oh, it's terrible, they're taking all our tax. They're taking too much tax. Commies, they're awful. Does he have a more sophisticated understanding of geopolitics, of how the economy works or anything? Or is it just gut, this is what I think?
却讨厌那些抹黑它的人吗？共产主义，我们必须与之抗争。”你知道的，他会抛出所有这些言论。大多数人都会点头称是，觉得这太棒了。而里根绝妙的一点在于——这招他是从《读者文摘》之类的地方学来的——他把这些观点包装成一则则寓言和小故事。他那日益右翼化的信念，难道比“哦，太糟糕了，他们在搜刮我们的所有税收”、“他们收的税太多了”、“共产主义者太可怕了”更深刻吗？他对地缘政治、经济运作方式或者其他什么有更深刻的理解吗？还是说这纯粹出于直觉：“这就是我的想法”？
Well, it's not just completely empty because he's reading these periodicals. Right. So he's got loads of... But it's not, I mean, it's not the Wall Street Journal, is it? No, he's not reading Edmund Burke. I mean, he's not pondering whether Viscount Bolingbroke was the real father of intellectual conservatism.
好吧，这倒也不是完全空洞，因为他在阅读这些期刊。没错。所以他肚子里有很多……但这并不是，我的意思是，这不是《华尔街日报》，对吧？没错，他读的可不是埃德蒙·伯克。我是说，他可不会去琢磨博林布鲁克子爵到底是不是知识保守主义的真正鼻祖。
No, but he's not reading, I don't know, strategic analysis from top geopoliticians or anything. It's not Margaret Thatcher reading Hayek or Dostoevsky. He's absolutely not that at all. And nor is he ever reading anything that would possibly contradict him. So he's reading things that confirm his, I was going to say prejudices, that's the wrong word. They confirm all his instincts. And that is kind of the key, isn't it?
不，但他读的也不是什么顶尖地缘政治学家的战略分析之类的东西。这可不像玛格丽特·撒切尔读海耶克或陀思妥耶夫斯基那样。他完全不是那种人。而且他也绝不会去阅读任何可能与他观点相左的东西。所以他读的东西都在不断强化他的——我本想说“偏见”，但这词不对。这些东西巩固了他的所有直觉。这才是关键所在，不是吗？
That is the key. But he doesn't need to kind of, I mean, so often politicians whose opinions are kind of informed by detailed study or academic study or whatever, they have to kind of lower it down a grade when they're kind of making their pitch. And so it sounds condescending or bogus or false or hypocritical. Yes. Whereas Reagan never had to do that because he is simply articulating what he feels. And his radio frequency is the radio frequency of so many of his listeners. Brilliant way of putting it, Tom. Actually, I think it's exactly the right way of putting it. I think there's nothing contrived about it. He reads up all the stuff. He has all the the facts he has all the stories to back up what he
这确实是关键所在。但他其实不需要去——我的意思是，很多时候，那些观点由细致研究或学术研究等内容塑造的政治家，在发表政治演说时必须把调子降下来。结果听起来就居高临下、虚伪、做作或言不由衷。是的。而里根从不需要这样做，因为他仅仅是在直抒胸臆。他的广播频率与他无数听众的广播频率同频共振。汤姆，这个比喻太绝了。实际上，我觉得这是最恰当不过的比喻了。我认为这里面没有任何矫揉造作的成分。他研读各种资料。他掌握了所有的
believes it's as you say it's what a lot of other people believe in the 1950s so the funny thing is this is eisenhower's america so it's definitely not a kind of socialist state by any means right but there's but there is a sense left over i think from antipathy to the new deal that you know the government is regulating a lot a lot, that we're paying too much tax, don't like communism, don't like interference, all these kinds of things. And Reagan is brilliant at articulating them. As you say, he's not kind of Ed Miliband. He hasn't been poring over policy documents.
事实、所有的故事来支撑他的信念。就像你说的，这正是50年代许多其他人所相信的。有趣的是，这是艾森豪威尔的美国——所以它绝对谈不上是什么社会主义国家，对吧？——但其中确实残存着一种对“新政”的反感情绪，即认为政府监管过多，我们交的税太多了，讨厌共产主义，讨厌干预，等等诸如此类。而里根非常擅长表达这些观点。正如你所说，他可不是什么埃德·米利班德。他可没有去苦心钻研政策文件。
Or indeed Margaret Thatcher. No, he's not Margaret Thatcher either. What it is, he has an extraordinary gift to bring these things alive through human stories and to create a sense of empathy with his audience. And his affable, charming manner means that even people who don't necessarily agree with him- Still like him. And enjoy the performance, actually. I mean, not everybody, of course.
或者说玛格丽特·撒切尔。不，他也不是玛格丽特·撒切尔。他的特质在于，他有一种非凡的天赋，能通过人类的故事让这些事情变得生动起来，并在听众中激发出一种共情。他那随和迷人的风度意味着，即便那些未必同意他观点的人——也依然会喜欢他。并且其实还会享受他的表演。当然，并非所有人都是如此。
But all the time, he's becoming more right wing. So I think it's not static. So he's been radicalized. He's talking to plant managers who say to him, well, the government red tape stops us. Because he visits 135 plants, I think, in the first year or two. In 25 states, 200,000 employees he shakes hands with. Extraordinary. The weird thing is that there's actually quite a parallel there with Gorbachev,
但他一直在变得越来越右倾。所以我觉得这不是一成不变的。他被激进化了。他跟那些工厂经理交谈，经理们对他说：“瞧，政府的繁文缛节阻碍了我们的发展。”因为他参观了135家工厂，我想是在最初的一两年里。在25个州，与20万名员工握手。太不可思议了。诡异的是，这其实与戈尔巴乔夫有相当大的相似之处，
who was kind of doing the same thing. Yeah. Gorbachev goes around plants. Yes, he does. But Reagan is doing it in such a systematic way. I mean, it's extraordinary. He's being exposed. There are so many people, actually, by the time he runs for president, who have... I mean, obviously, there are obviously a lot of people have seen him in films but there are so many people who would have met him at these or who would know people who would have met him at these general general electric employ a quarter of a million people and probably all of them have seen reagan at some point so he's being driven rightwards general electric get him this amazing house actually in um pacific palisades in california full of gizmos so he has the general electric house so he has a sort of swimming pool
他当时也在做类似的事情。是的。戈尔巴乔夫也到处去工厂视察。是的，确实如此。但里根做得如此系统化。我的意思是，这太非同寻常了。他一直在向公众曝光。事实上，到了他竞选总统的时候，有那么多人都曾——我的意思是，显然有很多人在电影里看过他，但也有相当多的人在这些场合亲眼见过他，或者认识在这些通用电气活动上见过他的人。通用电气雇用了四分之一百万名员工，其中可能所有人都曾在某个时刻见过里根，所以他正被一步步推向右翼。通用电气甚至在加州太平洋 Palisades 为他安排了一座极其惊艳的房子，里面摆满了各种高科技小玩意。所以他拥有那座“通用电气之宅”，甚至还有一个
with under with underwater lights they have to install a massive generator because it requires otherwise it would so it's actually circuit the whole of los angeles it actually sounds quite annoying in some ways so things like all the curtains are opened by remote controls. But I assume that there's some ginormous control room or keyboard. He has three fridges and two ovens. You very rarely need three fridges and two ovens, do you? I mean, I don't know. Maybe they do a lot of catering.
带水下照明的游泳池。他们不得不安装一个巨大的发电机，因为如果不这样的话，它会——事实上它会弄得整个洛杉矶都电路跳闸。从某些方面听起来其实挺烦人的。比如所有的窗帘都是通过遥控器打开的。但我猜那里一定有个巨大的控制室或者键盘。他有三个冰箱和两个烤箱。你很少需要三个冰箱和两个烤箱吧？我是说，我不知道。也许他们经常办宴席。
There is a definite tension, I think, emerging with General Electric because they don't want him to be too right-wing. So by the end of the 1950s, he definitely has become radicalized because when JFK becomes president in 1960, Reagan, he says, well, Kennedy is just offering Marxism.
我认为，他与通用电气之间确实正在产生一种紧张关系，因为通用电气并不希望他变得过于右翼。所以在50年代末期，他显然已经彻底被激进化了，因为当肯尼迪在1960年当选总统时，里根竟然说，肯尼迪宣扬的不过是马克思主义。
Yeah. You know, Kennedy is a Marxist. And at that point, you sort of say, oh, that's not quite your sort of standard middle-of-the-road Republican position. There's another very funny index of it, and I really don't need to tell you because this is your mastermind subject. But in 1952, Reagan's view on Nixon, who's running as Eisenhower's vice president, is very negative and describes him as less than honest and he is an ambitious opportunist, completely undeserving
是的。你知道的，肯尼迪是个马克思主义者。到了那个地步，你大概会觉得，这可不太符合你标准的中间派共和党立场。这里还有一个非常有趣的指标，其实我根本不需要告诉你，因为这是你的拿手好戏。但在1952年，里根对尼克松（当时作为艾森豪威尔的副总统候选人参选）的看法非常负面，他将尼克松形容为“算不上诚实”以及“一个野心勃勃的机会主义者”，完全不配
of the high honor accorded him. Not inaccurate. And then in 1960, when Nixon is running against Kennedy, oh, he wasn't the villain I thought him to be. Yeah. And of course, as time goes on, Reagan starts to think that Nixon is actually possibly a bit not rowing enough. A bit of a commie. Yeah. So he's definitely, he then is further enraged because I mentioned earlier that Reagan, when he was running the acting union, had brokered this deal for MCA, his agency, to get involved in TV production, which a lot of people thought was a very dodgy arrangement. And the Kennedy administration, the Justice Department look into this, and they're being run by Robert Kennedy. And Reagan develops this absolutely obsessive hatred
获得赋予他的崇高荣誉。这倒并非不准确。而在1960年，当尼克松与肯尼迪竞选时，哦，“他其实并不是我想象中的那个恶棍”。是的。当然，随着时间推移，里根开始觉得尼克松实际上可能有点……还不够纯粹。有点像个共产党。是的。所以他绝对——然后他更加被激怒了，因为我刚才提到过，里根在领导演艺工会时，曾为他的经纪公司MCA谈妥了一项交易，允许其涉足电视制作，许多人认为这是一个非常可疑的安排。而肯尼迪政府的司法部对此展开了调查，当时司法部由罗伯特·肯尼迪掌舵。里根因此对罗伯特·肯尼迪产生了绝对痴迷般的仇恨，
of Robert Kennedy, who he blames for everything that's sort of going wrong for him. Because about this point, General Electric Theatre's ratings started to climb. They're being beaten by Bonanza. And this is absolutely normal. I mean, this is what happens. You know, a show is, they've had a really good run, you know, eight years or so, and now they're going into decline. It's competition, isn't it? It's capitalism. It is.
他把所有发生在自己身上的倒霉事都归咎于罗伯特·肯尼迪。因为大约在这个时候，《通用电气剧场》的收视率开始下滑了。他们被《Bonanza》（大班车/荒野大镖客）给击败了。这其实很正常。我的意思是，这就是自然规律。你知道的，一个节目经历了一段非常辉煌的时期，大概八年左右，现在开始走下坡路了。这就是竞争，对吧？这就是资本主义。确实如此。
It's what right-wing Republicans are all in favour of. And General Electric think, well, Ron Reagan, he's getting a bit old. He's very right wing. He's a bit of a liability because he's also released a record. Have you seen this? No. Ronald Reagan speaks out against socialised medicine. It's not a song.
这正是右翼共和党人极力赞成的东西。而通用电气则认为，好吧，罗恩·里根，他有点老了。他太右翼了。他有点像个累赘，因为他还发行了一张唱片。你看过这个吗？没有。罗纳德·里根发表反对全民医疗保险的演讲。这不是一首歌。
It's not musical. Imagine him crooning to that. Yeah. Crooning about the dangers of socialised medicine. That's the sort of point Jim and Electric think. They say to him very politely, you know, the show is coming to an end. We'd love to have you stay on as an ambassador.
这不是音乐。想象一下他用轻柔低沉的嗓音哼唱那个。是的。哼唱着全民医疗保险的危害。这就是通用电气开始考虑问题的节点。他们非常礼貌地对他说，你知道的，节目要结束了。我们非常希望你能继续留任亲善大使。
So they're going to treat him properly. He's offended by that. He says, I'm not, you know, I'm still a part. Because deep down, I think, there's still a part of Reaganagan that wishes he was um still in hollywood i mean his last film the killers i mean that's early 1960s so there's still a bit of him the hankers for doing that and he plays a thug in that doesn't he does yeah very much against his better instincts see this is the thing he doesn't like paying the thug because he wants to always play himself he has to pretend to beat up angie dickinson who was he does reputedly one of kennedy's really i'm always golly there's something
所以他们打算好好款待他。但他被这番话冒犯了。他说：“我才不，你知道的，我依然是个演员……”因为在内心深处，我想，里根心里依然有一部分在渴望着自己能够呃，依然留在好莱坞。我是说，他的最后一部电影《杀手们》（The Killers）——我的意思是，那已经是20世纪60年代初了——所以他内心深处依然有一部分对那种生活恋恋不舍，他在片中扮演了一个暴徒，不是吗？演了，是的，这完全违背了他一贯的本能。看，这就是问题所在，他不喜欢扮演暴徒，因为他总是想扮演他自己。他不得不假装殴打安吉·迪金森，据传她也是肯尼迪的情人之一，真的吗？天哪，这其中有个
great metaphor there yeah deep water's there so he ends up hosting a lesser show sponsored by a company called us borax called death valley days is this the one that's been procured for him by moon his brother i think it might but yes Yes, because Moon becomes an advertising man, doesn't he? With McCann Erickson, I think. But it's at this point that politics calls. So that speech that you did so brilliantly, I have to say, Tom. Thank you. Thank you, Dominic.
绝妙的比喻，深不见底。所以他最后去主持了一档由一家名为美国硼砂公司（US Borax）赞助的、档次稍逊的节目，名叫《死谷日》（Death Valley Days）。这就是他弟弟穆恩为他揽下的那个节目吗？我觉得可能是的，没错，因为穆恩后来成了一个广告人，对吧？我记得是在麦肯光明广告公司（McCann Erickson）。但也就是在这个时候，政治在召唤他。所以你刚才表现得无懈可击的那段演讲，我必须说，汤姆。谢谢。谢谢你，多米尼克。
In a different league from your Marilyn Monroe, or indeed your Sopranos renditions that you've done on previous episodes of The Rest Is History. Thank you. So 1964, the Republicans nominate Barry Goldwater for president. Barry Goldwater's from Arizona. And he's really a libertarian rather than a conservative. I mean, Barry Goldwater's an absolutely fascinating man because he's very, very – he appears to be very much a man of the hard right. And yet, actually, he's in favour of gay rights,
这和你在之前几期《历史的 rest》节目中模仿的玛丽莲·梦露，或者说《黑道家族》片段相比，完全不是一个级别的。谢谢。所以1964年，共和党提名巴里·戈德华特竞选总统。巴里·戈德华特来自亚利桑那州。比起保守派，他其实更像是一个自由意志主义者。我的意思是，巴里·戈德华特是一个绝对迷人的人，因为他非常、非常——他看起来极像一个极右翼分子。然而实际上，他支持同性恋权利，
he's in favour of drug liberalisation, he supports abortion. He's actually a member of the NAACP, the Civil Rights Organisation, but he opposes civil rights legislation because he doesn't like federal government overreach. And also, the unfortunate thing for him is that it seems like he's in favour of nuclear war. Which is... Yes, at one point he says, he makes a series of gaffes. So he says he'd like to lob one into the men's room at the Kremlin. And he has the slogan, in your heart you know he's right, and the riposte is, in your heart you know he's right and the riposte is in your guts you know he's nuts yeah i mean he's saying he's on a hiding to nothing the year after the
他支持毒品合法化，他支持堕胎。他实际上还是全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）这个民权组织的成员，但他却反对民权立法，因为他不喜欢联邦政府的手伸得太长。而且，对她而言不幸的是，他看起来似乎在赞成核战争。这……是的，他曾在某个时刻发表了一系列失言。所以他说他很想把一枚核弹扔进克里姆林宫的男厕所里。他当时有一句竞选口号是：“你的内心深处知道他是对的”，而针锋相对的反击则是：“你的内心深处知道他是对的，但你的直觉告诉你他是个疯子”。是的，我的意思是，他在肯尼迪遇刺案发生的第二年，对阵林登·约翰逊，这场仗注定毫无胜算，而且许多温和派共和党人——与其说是尼克松，不如说是那种洛克菲勒派共和党人，纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，也就是来自纽约的大人物，他曾在那儿。
kennedy assassination running against lyndon johnson and a lot of moderate republicans so not so much nixon but kind of what rockefeller republicans nelson rockefeller who's the sort of the bigwig from new york he'd been there He was the sort of poster boy for liberal Republicans, and they all absolutely, you know, they thought Goldwater was a lunatic. Reagan obviously doesn't, and nor, crucially, do a load of Californian businessmen. So this guy called Holmes Tuttle. Of course there is.
他是自由派共和党人的海报男孩，而他们所有人都绝对——你知道的，他们觉得戈德华特简直是个疯子。里根显然不这么认为，而且至关重要的是，加州的一大批商人们也不这么认为。所以这个叫霍姆斯·特尔（Holmes Tuttle）的人。当然有这样的人。
So he handles kind of Ford car sales. There's a load of others. Henry Salvatore, who's oil. Cy Rubel is oil. Justin Dart is drugstores. So these are Californian businessmen, entrepreneurs. They are very suspicious of the kind of East Coast, very suspicious of Washington. They want lower taxes.
所以他经手福特汽车的销售业务。还有一大批其他人。亨利·萨尔瓦托（Henry Salvatore），搞石油的。赛·鲁贝尔（Cy Rubel），搞石油的。贾斯廷·达特（Justin Dart），开药妆店的。所以这些都是加州的商人和企业家。他们对东海岸充满怀疑，对华盛顿充满怀疑。他们希望减税。
They want less regulation, all these kinds of things. And it's Tuttle. He books a slot, a fundraiser at the Ambassador Hotel in LA, very famous kind of cabaret nightclub room they have called Coconut Grove. So the Ambassador Hotel is where Robert Kennedy ends up being shot in 1968. But they've booked this slot and they get Reagan to come in and do the talk. And of course, what you did, your rendezvous with Destiny, what precedes that is just Reagan's standard general electric talk, really. Low taxes,
他们希望减少监管，所有这些诸如此类的事情。就是特尔。他在洛杉矶的大使酒店（Ambassador Hotel）预订了一个场地，用来办一场筹款活动，那是一个非常有名的歌舞夜总会厅，名叫椰林俱乐部（Coconut Grove）。所以大使酒店就是1968年罗伯特·肯尼迪被枪杀的地方。但他们预订了这个场地，并请里根来做演讲。当然，你刚才做的那段——你的“命运的约会”之前铺垫的，其实就是里根标准的通用电气演讲。减税，
communism is evil. Barry Goldwater is a decent man who's going to roll back the federal government, all of this stuff. And he does it really superbly. He does it so well. Because he's been auditioning for it for a decade. Exactly. And he's got all the Reader's Digest facts. And he does it so well he's been auditioning for it for a decade exactly and he's got all the readers digest facts yeah and he does it brilliantly and they say golly it's so good we will we will buy half an hour tv time for the goldwater campaign as long as they put on reagan and actually some of the goldwater people say could we not actually put on gold no they say no no no it has to be has to be reagan and he he does it on tv you can see it
共产主义是邪恶的。巴里·戈德华特是一个正派的人，他将缩减联邦政府的权力，所有这些内容。他讲得简直绝妙。他发挥得太出色了。因为他这十年里一直在为这个进行“试镜”。完全正确。而且他掌握了《读者文摘》上的所有事实。他讲得太出色了，因为他这十年里一直在为此进行“试镜”，没错，他掌握了《读者文摘》的所有事实，是的，他讲得太棒了，以至于他们说：“天哪，这太棒了，我们要为戈德华特的竞选买下半小时的电视播出时间，条件是必须让里根上场。”事实上，有些戈德华特的人甚至问：“我们能不能不让戈德——”不，他们说：“不行，不行，必须是里根。”他上了电视，你可以在
on youtube um it's a it's a very you know it's it's pure undiluted kind of gold water reaganism but it's brilliantly delivered but if you had the sound turned down you didn't know he's giving a talk you could imagine it a kind of frank sinatra croon you could yeah that's the vibe yeah he commands the stage he has a sort of emollient mellifluous manner yeah he's he's very earnest he's very convincing i agree he could be it could be a sort of sinatra style performance and so basically people watch that and think actually reagan would be better than goldwater they do and is this the moment where people start thinking he could one day be president? He could perhaps, before that, be governor of California? Governor of California, certainly. Absolutely, they do. They look at Reagan. So another Hollywood
YouTube上看到它，呃，这是一段非常——你知道的，这是纯粹、未经稀释的戈德华特-里根主义，但它的演讲效果无与伦比。如果你把声音关掉，不知道他在做政治演讲，你甚至会以为这是一场弗兰克·辛纳屈式的深情浅唱。真的可以，就是那种氛围。他掌控了整个舞台，带着一种润泽悦耳的风度，是的，他非常诚挚，极具说服力。我同意，这完全可以是一场辛纳屈风格的表演。所以基本上，人们看了那个节目后觉得，其实里根比戈德华特更适合。他们确实这么觉得。这就是人们开始认为他有一天能当总统的时刻吗？他或许在那之前能先当加州州长？加州州长，那是肯定的。绝对是的，他们就是这么想的。他们看着里根。所以另一个好莱坞
actor, George Murphy, he's elected to the Senate from California. So the idea of a Hollywood actor going into politics is not automatically ludicrous. Plus, everything Reagan has done has been excellent training for a political campaign. His general electric plant visits, I mean, they're nothing if not campaign appearances. Shaking hands, a few jokes, a little bit of a political chat, and then off you go, goodbye. I mean, it's the most brilliant preparation for the challenge of any form of gubernatorial or presidential or whatever. Plus, it's not like he's just a front man because when they- He has deeply held prejudices.
演员乔治·墨菲（George Murphy），他从加州当选为参议员。所以好莱坞演员涉足政坛的想法并非天生荒谬。况且，里根所做的一切都是对政治竞选绝佳的训练。他在通用电气工厂的参观访问——我的意思是，它们无一不是竞选拉票活动。握手、开几个玩笑、聊一点政治，然后离开，再见。我的意思是，这是对任何形式的州长或总统或任何挑战的最辉煌的预热准备。况且，这可不是说他只是个挂名代言人，因为当他们——他拥有根深蒂固的偏见。
Right. He has very deeply held convictions. When he sits around with Holmes Tuttle or whoever it might be- Chewing the fat. Yeah, chewing the fat. I mean, he feels it just as strongly as they do and he knows all the stuff. So it's an obvious choice. So they come to him, 1965 or so, and they say, we've formed a group called the Friends of Ronald Reagan, and we would like you to run for governor of California. Okay, well, I think that's a perfect point to take a break. When we come back, we will look at Reagan's governorship and then the road to the presidency. I'm Marina Hyde.
没错。他有着极其坚定的信念。当他和霍姆斯·特尔或随便什么人坐在一起时——闲聊吹牛。是的，闲聊吹牛。我的意思是，他的感受和他们一样强烈，而且他对所有这些料都了如指掌。所以这是一个显而易见的选择。于是他们在1965年左右找到他，对他说：“我们成立了一个名为‘罗纳德·里根之友’的组织，我们希望你竞选加州州长。”好吧，我想这是个暂停的绝佳时机。当我们回来时，我们将关注里根的州长任期，然后是通往总统宝座之路。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐真相》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐产业的面纱，带你了解它的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Dominic, end of part one. You got us to the friends of Ronald Reagan gearing up to have their man run for the governorship of California in 1966. Is that right? 66, yeah. 66. So the 60s are really starting to swing.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史真相》。多米尼克，第一部分到此结束。你讲到了罗纳德·里根的朋友们开始筹备让他们的候选人在 1966 年竞选加州州长。是这样吗？66年，对。66年。所以 60 年代真的开始迎来高潮了。
California is one of the global epicenters of that. It's home of hippies and student protests and all that kind of thing. Meanwhile, Reagan is going in a very opposite direction. All the kind of the stuff that we associate with 1960s California, is that very much a minority interest? I think, well, every action provokes an equal and opposite reaction, I suppose you would say, Tom. So you're absolutely right that there's that scene in San Francisco.
加州是其中的全球中心之一。这里是嬉皮士、学生抗议以及各种此类现象的发源地。与此同时，里根正走向截然相反的方向。所有我们联想到1960年代加州的那些事物，真的只是极少数人的兴趣吗？我想，嗯，每一个作用力都会产生一个大小相等、方向相反的反作用力，汤姆，我想你会这么说。所以你绝对没说错，旧金山确实有那种亚文化圈。
There are free speech protests at universities or um filthy speech protests as as reagan calls them there's growing disquiet about the vietnam war the 60s sort of pop culture has is beginning to take that turn towards hippie hippiness and i mean that that sort of peaks in 1967 with the summer of love you know the the parks in san francisco full of people with flowers in their hair and whatnot. There's an enormous number of people in California, sort of suburban, middle-class, working-class people who don't buy into all that whatsoever. I mean, Reagan is brilliant at reaching them. So there are all these suburbs, particularly in Southern California, where there are people
大学里有言论自由抗议活动，或者用里根的话说是“肮脏言论抗议活动”；人们对越南战争的担忧日益加剧；60 年代的流行文化开始转向嬉皮士风格，我的意思是，这种风格在 1967 年的“爱之夏”达到了某种顶峰，你知道的，旧金山的公园里挤满了头上戴着花朵之类的各种人。加州有数量庞大的人——比如郊区居民、中产阶级、工人阶级——他们根本不买账。我的意思是，里根在争取这些人方面堪称天才。所以有这么多郊区，特别是南加州，那里有这样一群人：
who have moved in from elsewhere. So they've moved in from the Midwest, like Reagan, actually, or they've moved from Texas or Oklahoma. So they bring with them quite conservative attitudes. They've started churches there. They meet at coffee mornings. And there's this sort of nascent conservative movement in particularly Southern California. Orange County is the place that people always point to, which is just outside Los Angeles. So that's all kind of getting started.
他们从其他地方搬来。实际上他们像里根一样从美国中西部搬来，或者从得克萨斯州或俄克拉何马州搬来。所以他们带来了相当保守的态度。他们在那里建立了教堂。他们在早晨的咖啡聚会上见面。尤其是在南加州，正在孕育着这样一种初具规模的保守派运动。人们总是会提到洛杉矶郊外的奥兰治县。所以这一切都开始萌芽了。
But also, California has been run by a guy called Pat Brown, Edmund G. Brown, who is a kind of classic. You know, if a Hollywood casting agency had to supply a kind of Irish pole, he is the man. And again and again through this story this is something that comes up the casting agents they they look like they've been supplied by casting agency yeah so and pat brown absolutely looks like i mean he's a tremendous fellow in lots of ways two-term governor he's he's basically one of the people who has made modern california he has spent loads of money i mean arguably too much money, as Reagan will discover. So they're running a big deficit, but they've built schools and universities and all of these things.
但同时，加州一直由一个叫帕特·布朗（埃德蒙·G·布朗）的人统治，他是一个典型的人物。你知道，如果好莱坞选角公司必须提供一个爱尔兰政客类型的角色，他就是不二人选。在这整个故事中，这件事一再出现——这些选角公司的演员们，看起来就像是选角公司精挑细选出来的。所以帕特·布朗看起来完全就是这样——从很多方面来看，他都是个了不起的家伙，两届州长，他基本上是塑造现代加州的人之一。他花了大量的钱，可以说钱花得太多了，正如里根后来所发现的那样。所以他们背负着巨额赤字，但他们建造了学校、大学以及所有这些设施。
They've really built the infrastructure of modern California. But he's been in for two terms. There's a sense, particularly among these quite conservative middle class suburban parts of the population, that's too much waste the tax is too high there's disquiet of course about racial unrest because you've had things like watts you've had um the civil it's not that the civil rights movement has sort of turned sour or anything but there have been a wave of urban riots that alarm kind of suburban white homeowners. There's a sort of a dark turn, I suppose you would say. So in the first episode, we talked about how Reagan's father had been very, very opposed to any hint of racial prejudice. Yes.
他们真正奠定了现代加州的基建。但他已经干了两届了。人们有一种感觉，特别是在这些相当保守的中产阶级郊区选民当中，这是一种极大的浪费，税收太高了。当然，人们对种族骚乱感到不安，因为你们经历了瓦茨骚乱之类的事情，经历了民权运动——倒不是说民权运动变味了什么的，而是有一波城市骚乱让郊区的白人房主感到惊慌。我想你可以说，局势出现了一种黑暗的转折。所以在第一集中，我们讨论过里根的父亲如何非常、非常反对任何种族偏见的迹象。是的。
And this was kind of late 20s, early 30s. Has Reagan's attitude to this evolved? No, I would say. In a kind of rightwards way? I mean, what's his attitude to the kind of the racial tensions in California at this evolved? No, I would say- In a kind of rightwards way? I mean, what's his attitude to the racial tensions in California at this time? This is a very fraught subject and much sort of discussed by Reagan biographers and historians. Reagan himself doesn't seem to have had any personal prejudice at all. There's a very famous incident when he's at Eureka College.
这大约是在 20 年代末、30 年代初。里根对此的态度演变了吗？没有，我想说。是以某种向右倾斜的方式吗？我是说，他对加州当时这种种族紧张局势的态度是如何演变的？没有，我想说——是以某种向右倾斜的方式？我是说，他对当时加州种族紧张局势的态度是怎样的？这是一个非常棘手的话题，里根的传记作家和历史学家对此进行了很多讨论。里根本人似乎没有任何个人偏见。有一个非常著名的事件，当他在尤里卡学院时。
There are two black young men on the team. They turn up to play somewhere and it turns out to be segregated. And Reagan says, we're not actually that far from my home, from Dixon, I assume he's living in that point. He says, I'll take these two guys home with me and we'll stay at my house. And people have often sort of said, well, there you go. Reagan's not racist at all. I think what is probably fair to say is that Reagan is always, he dislikes the idea of the federal government intervening in terms of civil rights. So he thinks it should be left to the states. This is part of his sort of small governmentism, I think. But it's also true to say that from the late 60s onwards, to get ahead in Republican politics, as the Republican Party
队里有两个年轻的黑人小伙子。他们去某个地方打比赛，结果发现那里实行种族隔离。里根说：“我们离我的家、离迪克森其实不算太远”——我猜他当时住在那里。他说：“我把这两个小伙子带回我家，他们会住在我家。”人们经常说：“看吧，里根一点也不种族歧视。”我想可能比较公平的说法是，里根一直以来——他不喜欢联邦政府在民权问题上进行干预。所以他认为这应该留给各州去处理。我认为这是他奉行的小政府主义的一部分。但同样不可否认的是，从 60 年代末开始，为了在共和党政治中脱颖而出，随着共和党变得更加南方化，并开始极大地依赖南方的白人选民，所谓“狗哨政治”（暗示性言论）就从不遥远。里根在这个阶段已经在做的一件事，就是讲述一些明显关于黑人的寓言。因此他讲得最著名的寓言就是“福利女王”。他说，芝加哥有一个女人，有 80 个名字、30 个地址、12 张社保卡，领取老兵津贴和四个死去的丈夫。她拥有 15 万美元的免税现金收入。他从来没有明说，但所有听众都心知肚明，这个人是个黑人。顺便说一句，这个人根本不存在，或者说并不存在于他所描述的程度。这个寓言在里根的批评者看来，
becomes more southernized and starts to rely very heavily on southern white voters. The dog whistle, as it were, is never far away. And the one thing that Reagan is already doing at this stage is he's telling parables about people who are clearly black. So the most famous parable that he tells is the welfare queen. He says, there's a woman in Chicago with 80 names, 30 addresses, 12 social security cards, collecting veterans benefits and four dead husbands. She has a tax-free cash income of $150,000. And he never says it, but the understanding of all his listeners is that this person is black. Now, this person, by the way, doesn't exist or this doesn't exist to the degree that he describes. And this parable seems to, to Reagan's critics,
这个寓言就是一种狗哨式的言论，意思是：拿救济金的黑人在花着你们的纳税钱，让我们削减这些开支吧。你是否也认为——我是说，关于那些出身极其贫寒却取得巨大成功的人，有一种普遍的看法，他们经常说：“既然我都做到了，任何人都能做到。”在美国，总统出身于木屋、美国梦以及所有诸如此类的宏大叙事。
this parable is a kind of dog whistle to say, black people on welfare, taking your taxes, let's cut down on this. Do you think also, I mean, a common thing about people from very poor backgrounds who become very successful, they often say, well, I've done it, so anyone can do it. And in America, the whole idea of the president coming from a log cabin, the American dream, all that kind of stuff.
我是说，你刚才提到，里根来自一个文化上非常白人的背景。所以他在成长过程中，可能并没有意识到美国黑人要克服远比他多得多的障碍。是的，我确信是这样的。我是说，是不是到了 60 年代，他环顾四周，然后说：“好吧，我都成功了。为什么所有这些正在暴动黑人，他们为什么不走出去，靠自己的力量自力更生呢？”我是说，这就是他的看法吗？毫无疑问。
I mean, you said, you know, Reagan has come from a culturally very white background. And so he hasn't grown up with an awareness of the way perhaps in which black Americans have far more obstacles to overcome. Yeah, I'm sure that's true. I mean, is it the case that by the 60s, he's looking around and saying, well, I've made it. Why can't all these black people who are rioting, why aren't they getting out there and pulling themselves up by their bootstraps? I mean, is that his take? Undoubtedly.
如果你对他说——我是说，有几句名言。我想尼克松的录音带里有这么一段，当他谈到非洲国家批评美国时，他用了“猴子”这个词来形容非洲领导人或者其他什么人。但除此之外，除了那个题外话，并没有大量无可辩驳的证据来表明里根内心深处是一个恶毒的种族主义者。但他没有正视自己的白人特权，正如现在的年轻人可能会说的那样。正如年轻人会说的那样。我认为公平地说，他本能地敌对任何形式的联邦干预——不仅是为了非洲裔美国人，也为了广大穷人，我认为他是视而不见的。
If you said to him, I mean, there are a couple of quotes. I think there's something on the Nixon tapes when he's talking about African countries criticizing the United States. He uses the word monkeys to describe the African leaders or something. But there aren't really, apart from that aside, there are not loads of smoking guns to say Reagan deep down is a vicious racist. But he's failing to check his white privilege, as the kids might put it now. As the youth would say. I think it's fair to say that he is instinctively hostile to any form of federal intervention on behalf of not just African-Americans, but also the poor generally, I think, and blind.
许多人会说他对这个问题视而不见。而且他也是——在必要时，他和他的顾问们是愿意这么做的。当他在 1980 年竞选总统时，我们就会看到他发表了一次非常著名的竞选演讲。他愿意向那些种族观点绝对谈不上进步的人“抛媚眼”（讨好）。于是他赢得了共和党总统候选人提名，接着又赢得了州长职位。这一切都发生在嬉皮士们把鲜花插进国民警卫队的枪管里以及诸如此类的事情发生的同时。他确实通过了一项堕胎法案，但他对此深感后悔。治疗性堕胎法案，对吧？这在当时实际上是全美最自由的堕胎立法之一。
A lot of people would say he's just blind to this issue. And he is also, he is willing and his advisors are willing where necessary. And we'll see it when he runs for the presidency in 1980 with a very famous campaign appearance that he made. He is willing to, as it were, show a bit of leg to people whose views on race are definitely not progressive at all. So he wins the Republican nomination to run for the governorship, and then he wins the governorship itself. And this is all going on while hippies are putting flowers in the guns of the National Guard and all that kind of stuff. He does pass an abortion bill, but he deeply regrets it. Therapeutic abortion bill, right? Which is actually at the time, some of the most liberal abortion legislation in the nation.
加州拥有全美最自由的一些堕胎立法。但里根后来开始后悔了，不是吗？好吧，汤姆，这正是里根作为政治操盘手的本质所在，这也是他如此迷人的原因。他说他后来后悔了，但他还是把它签署了。好吧。里根作为一名政治操盘手之所以如此有趣，是因为他那非常尖锐的言辞和某种世俗的、读者文摘式的世界观，与他在加州实际上表现得像一个非常务实的中右翼州长这一事实之间形成了鲜明对比。所有研究他那一时期的人，从写了第一本真正伟大的里根传记的卢·坎农开始，到尤宁·摩根，所有里根的传记作家，他们都谈到里根在加州时，实际上是个相当不错的州长。那么他通过了什么立法？他做了什么？我是说，他的标志性政绩是什么？他在学校上花了很多钱。他与民主党占绝对多数的州议会达成了一项赤字削减计划，这使得加州的各项税收全面上涨了大约十亿美元。所以税收是上升了，而不是下降了。他引入了汽车尾气污染管制。事实上，他在环保方面非常积极。
California has some of the most liberal abortion legislation. But Reagan comes to regret it, doesn't he? Well, Tom, this is the essence of Reagan as an operator. What makes him so fascinating. He says he regrets it later on, but he still signs it. Yeah. Okay. And Reagan, what makes him so interesting as a political operator is the contrast between the very hard-hitting rhetoric and the sort of human events, readers digest view of the world with the fact that in California, for example, he turns out to be a very pragmatic, kind of centre-right governor. And everybody who studied his period, as Lou Cannon,
他阻止了一座水库大坝的修建。他阻止了一条高速公路的修建。哦，对的。他骑着马去了他们想要炸毁的山脊，对吧？他骑着马，带着媒体记者，骑在马上。他说：“你们怎么会想毁掉这一切呢？你知道，这条高速公路必须停建。”诸如此类的事情。
who wrote the first really great books about Reagan, onwards, Ewan Morgan, all Reagan's biographers, they all say about Reagan in California, he was actually a pretty good governor. So what legislation, what does he do? I mean, what are his signature? He spends a lot of money on schools. He agrees a deficit reduction plan with the democratic dominated legislature that sees taxes go up in California across the board by about a billion dollars. So taxes up, not down. He introduces controls on sort of car pollution. He's very environmental, actually.
因为他被环绕着——这就是他学习如何治理国家的地方。因为他刚上任时说：“我从来没演过州长，我不知道该做什么。”是的。他有一个叫比尔·克拉克的顾问，琢磨出他们该如何施政。他设计了一种后来遭到里根批评者极力嘲讽的东西，叫做“迷你备忘录”。基本上，当你给里根一份文件时，它必须只有一页纸。它分为四个段落。第一段说明问题是什么；第二段是一些背景信息；第三段列出备选方案；第四段是：
He blocks a dam. He blocks a highway. Oh, that's right. He rides up, doesn't he, to a mountain ridge that they want to blast away. He goes on his horse, takes the press, and he's on his horse. And he says, how would you want to destroy all this? You know, the highway must stop. All these kinds of things.
这就是我们应该做的。他说，这就是我们将信息呈交给州长的方式。他不需要太多内容。他不像玛格丽特·撒切尔那样，想要每一份可能的文件，并且要一直研读到凌晨五点。里根只想立刻做出决定，把所有事情浓缩精简。在周围聪明、务实的人的协助下，他实际上被证明非常擅长掌控权柄、与议会在合作。
Because he's surrounded by, this is where he learns how to govern. Because when he arrives, he says, I've never played a governor. I don't know what to do. Yeah. And he has an advisor called Bill Clark who works out how they're going to do it. He works out a thing that's later much mocked by Reagan's critics of what's called mini memos. So basically, when you give Reagan a piece of paper, it must be just a page. And it's four paragraphs. Paragraph one says, what's the problem? Paragraph two is a bit of background. Paragraph three, here are the options. And paragraph four is,
他在 1970 年赢得连任。所以实际上，他因——我是说，他在整个州长任期内说过最有名的一句话是在嘲讽嬉皮士的时候。他说：“嬉皮士的定义就是，长得像泰山，走起路来像珍，闻起来像猎豹。”没错。当然，嬉皮士运动、反文化运动，为他提供了完美的反对派。
this is what we should do. He says, this is how we will present information to the governor. He doesn't want too much. He's not Margaret Thatcher, who wants every possible piece of paper and is going to go through them all till five o'clock in the morning. Reagan just wants to make a decision straight away and have it all boiled down. And with smart people around him, pragmatic people, he actually proves very good at pulling the levers, working with the legislature.
但我想我会说的是，里根对他们来说是一个十恶不赦的形象，他也确实批评他们、攻击他们，诸如此类。但其中有一种幽默感，一种带有讽刺意味的边缘感。你知道，实际上——里根并不是一个擅长兜售仇恨的政客。你知道的，所以他喜欢包容、受欢迎、幽默以及所有这些东西，这当然使他成为保守派意识形态的极佳推销员。没错。
He wins re-election in 1970. So actually, he is famous for, I mean, the most famous thing he probably says in his whole governorship is when he's mocking hippies. And he says, the definition of a hippie is somebody who looks like Tarzan, walks like Jane and smells like Cheetah. Right. And of course, the hippie movement, the counterculture, gives him the perfect opposition.
好的。这就是进入 70 年代的情况。这是尼克松总统任期以及所有这些事情。尼克松赢得了他的第二个任期。所以如果他完成任期，那他就卸任了。因此，到这个时候，里根心里一定在想：这是我的机会。但接着发生了“水门事件”。这意味着尼克松由他的副总统杰拉尔德·福特接任，里根曾在福特当年打大学橄榄球时担任过体育解说员，并对福特进行过解说。尽管里根后来因福特摔下飞机而闻名——
But I suppose what I would say about that is Reagan is a hate figure for them, and he does criticize them, attack them, and all the rest of it. But there is a kind of hume, a wry edge to it. You know, he's actually – Reagan is not actually a politician who's very good at peddling hate, as it were. You know, so he likes being inclusive and being well-liked and being funny and all those kinds of things, which makes him such a good salesman, of course, for conservative ideology. Right.
切维·切斯曾模仿他摔倒的样子——但福特可能是历史上最伟大的运动员总统。他是个非常优秀的髙尔夫球手，对吧？他做什么都行。我的意思是，他是一个极其出色的橄榄球运动员，本可以成为职业球员。所以这把里根的计划全打乱了。当然是的。
Okay. And so this is the, going into the seventies. This is the Nixon presidency, all that kind of stuff. Nixon's won his second term. So he will, you know, if he serves out his term, that will be him done. And so Reagan by this point must be thinking, this is my chance. But then Watergate happens. And that means that Nixon gets succeeded by his vice president, Gerald Ford, on whom Reagan had commentated as a sportscaster back in the days when Ford had played college football and Reagan had commentated on him. Although he's later famous for falling off aeroplanes
当然是的。但福特很脆弱。所以福特绝对想在 1976 年再次参选。但里根可以挑战他。这里面存在各种各样的弱点。他们刚刚经历了——1975 年越南陷落。1973 年石油危机之后，经济状况相当糟糕。
and Chevy Chase would impersonate him falling over, Ford was probably the greatest athlete to have ever been president. He was a very good golfer, wasn't he? He was good at everything. I mean, he was a really, really good footballer to have ever been president. He's a very good golfer, wasn't he? He's good at everything. I mean, he was a really, really good footballer. Could have been professional. So this messes things up for Reagan. Definitely it does.
所以遭遇了经济衰退。他们也因缓和政策而挨了不少骂。因为尼克松以及后来的福特，在亨利·基辛格的辅佐下，对苏联奉行了缓和政策，这是铁杆反共人士绝对不喜欢的。此外，政治显然越来越关乎风格，也就是今天人们所说的“氛围”。而福特并不具备新右翼和保守派运动所需要的正确氛围，因为他是个老派的共和党人。我的意思是，他依然抽着烟斗。
Definitely. But Ford is vulnerable. So Ford definitely wants to run again in 1976. But Reagan can challenge him. There are all sorts of weaknesses. They've just, you know, Vietnam falls in 1975. The economy is in a pretty poor condition post oil shock of 1973.
在他家乡的乡村俱乐部里。正在崛起的“阳光地带”。也就是南方和西南部，这些人口大幅增长、充满新保守主义、普及了空调、涌入大量新工厂、反工会、极其宗教化的地区。里根能赢得这些人的支持，而福特做不到。于是里根决定挑战福特。这实际上是里根——他是个常胜将军，但唯一真正击败过他的人就是福特。是福特，因为他在争夺共和党总统候选人提名的竞选中输了。确实如此，他找到了几个对他非常奏效的竞选主张。其中之一就是对亨利·基辛格的攻击，以及关于“世界老二”的论调——我的意思是他在 1980 年会再次抛出这个论调。所以他说，我们已经被沦为世界老二，我们是美国，我们绝不能成为世界老二。所以这是其一。另一件事是一个现在完全被遗忘的议题，那就是巴拿马运河。没错，美国——这非常像 1890 年代的法国。确实如此。但在 20 世纪 70 年代的基层保守派中，巴拿马运河是一个极其重大的议题。所以福特以及后来的吉米·卡特将达成一项协议，基本上把巴拿马运河交还给巴拿马，因为巴拿马人一直在强烈敦促这样做。里根提出了这样一个竞选口号。他在 1976 年的佛罗里达州初选中提出了这个口号，并在接下来的整个初选季中一直使用：我们买下的。我们付了钱。我们建造的。我们要买下的。我们付了钱。我们建造的。我们要留着它。
So there's a recession. They're also getting a lot of flack for detente. So Nixon and then Ford with Henry Kissinger at their side have pursued a policy of detente with the Soviet Union, which hardcore anti-communists don't like at all. Also, politics is obviously becoming increasingly about style, about what people today call vibes. And Ford does not have the correct vibes for the new rights for the conservative movement, because he's a sort of old fashioned Republican. I mean, he still does smoke a pipe.
人们对此狂热不已。你知道，那些顶着蓝色头发的人，那些蓝发贵妇。把牛仔帽扔向空中。正是如此。但福特作为总统的体制优势太巨大了。再加上里根有点——他说了一些蠢话。所以在某个阶段，他说他要将联邦预算削减，是多少来着？
At his country club. emerging sunbelt. So that's the South and the Southwest, these areas where massive population growth, new conservatism, air conditioning, so lots of new factories coming in, anti-union, very religious. Reagan can reach those people and Ford can't. So Reagan decides he will challenge Ford. And it's actually the one time Reagan is a serial winner, but the only person who ever really beats him is Ford. is ford because he loses those that run for the for the republican nomination he does he does he finds a couple of lines that work very well for him so one is is attacks on henry kissinger and this stuff about being number two in the world i mean he'll bring that out again in 1980 so he says we have been relegated to number
大约 900亿美元左右。所以例如，佛罗里达州依赖社会保障的退休人员——也就是基本上靠政府支持的养老金生活的人——他们对此感到惊恐万状。所以他有点——他吓唬了选民，他还没有找到一种方法来淡化或很好地呈现他那种读者文摘式的世界观。此外，他还——他差点在一颗花生上噎死。这是真的。他把一颗花生抛向空中，然后像海狮一样用嘴接住，结果差点噎死。我猜南茜的占星师会说这是一个凶兆，因为 1976 年总统大选真正的赢家是一个花生农场主。这就是吉米·卡特。吉米·卡特。
two in the world we're america we can never be number two in the world. So that's one thing. The other thing is an issue that's now completely forgotten, which is the Panama Canal. So yes, the United States. That's very France in 1890. It is. But the Panama Canal is a massive, massive issue among grassroots conservatives in the 1970s. So Ford and then later Jimmy Carter are going to agree a deal to basically turn the Panama
所以杰拉尔德·福特输了。那么可以推断，这个梦想依然活着？绝对是的。尽管到这个时候里根已经相当老了，对吧？对，对。他将成为最年长的总统。此时此刻，是的。所以我想他参加 1980 年竞选时是 68 岁。
Canal over to Panama because the Panamanians are pressing very vigorously for it. And Reagan develops this line. He develops it in the Florida primary in 1976 and then use it throughout the rest of the primary season. We bought it. We paid for it. We built it. And we're going to bought it. We paid for it. We built it. And we're going to keep it.
他在 1976 年躲过了一颗“花生”的劫难。因此，他的传记作家之一尤宁·摩根（英国历史学家、非常伟大的学者）对里根做出这样的评价：如果里根在 1976 年赢得了提名，很难想象他能击败卡特。卡特是局外人。人们对水门事件有着强烈的反感，而且卡特在南方势力非常强大。卡特是几代人中第一个赢得白宫的南方人。
And people love that. You know, they're kind of people with blue hair, kind of ladies with blue hair. Throwing Stetsons in the air. Exactly. But the institutional advantages for Ford as president are too great. Plus Reagan is a little, he says silly things. So there's a point at which he says he's going to cut the federal budget by, what is it,
当时的卡特带着灿烂的笑容、积极向上的氛围，以及所有这些东西。他还没有遭到他那只“杀手兔”的攻击，还没有穿上他的开衫，也没有在慢跑时晕倒，或者经历任何这些倒霉事。关于卡特和里根，一个迷人的事实是，卡特——这有点像我们在《历史真相》中讨论过好几次的话题，即党派政治和党派斗争背后历史的底层延续性。卡特在 1976 年打着反华盛顿的旗号竞选。卡特把自己描述为一个平民政治家，一个普通的美国人，而不是一个职业政客，他说，
something like $90 billion. And so for example, retirees in Florida who depend on social security, on the sort of government-backed pensions effectively um they're horrified by this so he sort of he frightens voters he hasn't found a way of of sort of diluting or presenting his his reader's digested kind of view of the world well he also um he almost chokes to death on a peanut that's true he's he kind of throws a peanut up in the air and catches it like a seal or something and almost chokes to death. And I guess that Nancy's astrologer would say that this was a portent because the person who actually wins the 76 presidential election is a peanut farmer. Here's Jimmy Carter. Jimmy Carter.
这正是里根在加州时所说的话。卡特赞成减税和放松管制，事实上，他开启了放松管制的进程，里根后来继承了这一进程。卡特是个南方人，而美国政治正变得南方化。不仅南方变得越来越重要，而且南方的价值观——比如家庭、教堂、国旗、军队、军方——所有这些东西，在广大蓝领选民中变得越来越受欢迎。卡特显然是一位浸信会教徒、福音派基督徒，他是第一个公开宣称的福音派基督徒——本来会在 1976 年击败卡特。所以里根可以说是躲过了一劫。
So Gerald Ford loses. And so that presumably then the dream stays alive. Absolutely. Even though Reagan is pretty old by this point, right? Yeah, yeah. He would be the oldest president. At this point, yes. So 68, I think, when he runs in 1980.
但在接下来的四年里，卡特诸事不顺。因此，伊朗伊斯兰革命就是最明显的例子。发生了能源危机。我对卡特担任总统的看法相当不客气。我认为无论如何他也算不上一个好总统。我认为他出了很多状况，犯了许多失误。我的意思是，他做过的最糟糕的一件事，可能是一种弥漫的负面情绪。所以在 1979 年年中，他发表了一场非常著名的演讲，谈到美国人民正遭受着一种深重的“社会悲观情绪”（malaise）的困扰。
He dodges a peanut, as it were, in 1976. So one of his biographers, Ewan Morgan, British historian, very great scholar, says of Reagan, had Reagan won the nomination in 1976, it's hard to imagine him beating Carter. Carter is the outsider. There's a lot of revulsion about Watergate, but also Carter is very strong in the South. Carter's the first Southerner for generations to win the White House.
而且气氛非常阴暗。卡特总是告诉人们：“不要浪费电，关掉电灯。”我的意思是，从 2023 年的视角来看，我们可能会说这些都是非常明智的建议。与此同时，里根却拥有他的 10 台冰箱。再拿一个南茜来。不仅如此，卡特。卡特还做了一些诸如在圣诞节时关掉白宫的灯以节约用电之类的事。他穿着——他想表现得像个普通人，所以他穿着开衫，白宫里没有宏伟的气象，
Carter, at that point, has a kind of big smile, positive vibes, all that kind of stuff. He hasn't yet been attacked by his killer rabbit or worn his cardigan or collapsed jogging or any of those things. A fascinating thing about Carter and Reagan is that Carter, it's a bit like, well, we've talked about this a few times in the rest of his history, the underlying continuities of history beneath partisan politics and partisan struggles. So Carter runs against Washington in 1976. Carter describes himself as a citizen politician, just an ordinary American, not a career politician, he says,
卡特身上没有任何乐观主义可言。所以里根提供的是爽朗的乐观主义和好莱坞的魅力。是的，而且——我完全能理解这为什么会如此有效。所有的潮流也对里根极为有利。正如我刚才所说，阳光地带的崛起和南方化是一方面，而且里根在 80 年代末还拥有了一个他以前并不真正拥有的新选区，那就是基督教右翼。也就是道德多数派（Moral Majority）之类的人。在某些人看来，这在某种程度上显得很诡异。这预示着日后某些人对他们接纳特朗普时感到的那种轻微困惑。人们会说，里根不是那个好莱坞的、离过婚的好莱坞演员吗？是的，因为卡特本来会是一个更显而易见的——当然，里根到处讲荤段子，
which is what Reagan had said in California. Carter is in favor of lower taxes and deregulation, and in fact, starts the move towards deregulation, which Reagan then inherits. Carter is a Southerner, and American politics is becoming southernized. It's not just that the South is becoming more and more important, but kind of southern values, the kind of family, church, flag, the army, the military, all these things, they are becoming more and more popular among blue-collar voters generally. Carter is obviously a Baptist, an evangelical Christian, the first overtly evangelical Christian to would have beaten Carter in 1976. So Reagan has dodged the bullet, as it were.
他曾有过——他怎么称呼他过去的那些女友来着？“我过去的那些可卡犬”。为了对里根公平起见，我的意思是，我猜他其实和吉米·卡特一样是一个虔诚的基督徒。而且从本性上看，他似乎非常专一。所以，基督教右翼手中确实有可以利用的素材。他们热爱他的反共立场。
But then in the next four years, lots of things go wrong for Carter. So the Iranian revolution is the most obvious example of that. There's an energy crisis. I take quite a disobliging view of Carter as president. I think he's not a very good president by any stretch of the imagination. I think he gets lots of things, makes a lot of missteps. I mean, the single worst thing he does is probably an air of negativity. So he gives a very famous speech in the middle of 1979 about there's a profound malaise affecting the American people.
他们热爱他炽热的爱国主义。他们之所以真正投入里根的怀抱，是因为在卡特执政期间，美国国税局（IRS）宣布他们将开始对被称为“种族隔离私立学校”的私立学校征税。因此，大量私立学校如雨后春笋般涌现，以吸引那些对南方学校取消种族隔离感到惊恐万状的家长。也就是富有的种族主义者。是的，我想这——好吧，我的意思是，其实不仅是富人。好吧。
And it's all very gloomy. And Carter is always telling people, you know, don't waste electricity, turn off the lights. I mean, we might say from the vantage point of 2023 that these are very sensible suggestions. Meanwhile, Reagan with his 10 fridges. Let's get another Nancy. But also Carter. Carter does things like, Carter turns off the lights at the White House at Christmas to save electricity. He sort of swans around in his, he wants to be an an ordinary person so he wears his cardigan and there's no grandeur
我是说，这些学校在南方变得极其、极其受欢迎。而国税局表示，如果你不能证明你们拥有一个场地——你知道的，即你们反映了你所在州的种族构成或其他情况，那么你们将不再享有免税资格。这彻底激怒了支持这些学校的许多教会。这意味着他们与吉米·卡特彻底决裂了。而里根拥有一套接触他们的绝妙方法。他在 1980 年去参加了宗教圆桌会议，
there's no optimism about carter and so what reagan offers is cheery optimism and hollywood glamour yeah and and so yeah i can see how that would be effective and all the trends as well are in reagan's favor so i said about the sort of the growth of the Sun Belt and southernization, but also Reagan has a new constituency at the end of the 80s that he didn't really have before, which is the Christian right. So the moral majority, people like that. And it seems weird in some ways to people. It anticipates the slight bewilderment with which some people regard their adoption of
这是所有福音派大咖的这场盛大聚会。他对他们说：“我知道你们不能公开背书我，但我希望你们知道，我支持你们以及你们正在做的事。”这真是大师级的操作，每个人都欢呼雀跃：“噢，多么了不起的家伙！”诸如此类。所以，是的，他赢得了共和党提名——他在 70 年代一直四处奔走、写作、上电台。我的意思是，里根是电台广播的大师。如果你读过一本——我想书名叫《里根亲笔书写》之类的书，里面收录了他所有的电台广播稿。他本可以成为一个出色的专栏作家。好吧，他本来就是个出色的专栏作家。他写过专栏。他写这些五分钟的广播稿，总是
Donald Trump. People sayagan is this a hollywood hollywood divorcee yeah because carter would be a more obvious of course reagan goes around telling dirty jokes yeah he has he has what did he call his the string of girls uh the cocker spaniels in his past you know to be fair to reagan i mean he he is as devout a Christian as Jimmy Carter, I guess. And he's very monogamous by nature, he seems, actually. So there is material there for the Christian right to work with. They love his anti-communism.
以一个小故事开头。有一天我在超市里，我前面有一个人，一个身材魁梧的小伙子。他买了 72 袋商品。然后我忍不住注意到他是用福利救济券付的账。我心里想，我到底做错了什么，为什么这家伙靠救济金过日子，而我的税却——你的税钱都流向了。是的。没错。玛格丽特·撒切尔即便在民粹主义方面相当有一套，但也远没有他那么高明。所以他有一种把人们吸引过来的方式。他赢得了共和党提名。他击败了乔治。乔治·布什是他的强劲对手。人们仍然对他是否过于右翼存有一丝疑虑。实际上，这也是卡特的巨大希望，因为卡特的总统任期在 1980 年基本上已经坠入了一个绝对的深渊。人质事件仍在伊朗持续。杀手兔
They love his fervent patriotism. They are really driven into Reagan's embrace because under Carter, the IRS, the Internal Revenue Service, announced that they're going to start taxing private schools that are what are called segregation academies. So there's been a huge explosion of private schools that have been formed to appeal to parents who are horrified by the desegregation of Southern schools. So rich racists. Yeah, I suppose that's, well, I mean, it's not just rich, actually. Okay.
在佛罗里达州的沼泽地里游荡。一团糟。嗯，经济陷入衰退。他新任的美联储主席、一个叫保罗·沃尔克的人，是个货币主义者，他的态度是：既然我们面临巨大的通货膨胀，那就狠狠加息吧。所以利率正朝着 20% 迈进。苏联入侵了阿富汗。对卡特而言，所有的消息都是坏消息。人质事件是其中最糟糕的一个。远远是最糟糕的。因为这是一场旷日持久的、每晚都在新闻里上演的恐怖秀。
I mean, these schools becoming extremely, extremely popular in the south. And the IRS says, if you don't show that you have a site, you know, that you're reflecting the sort of racial makeup
而且人质被劫持的时间恰好是 1980 年总统大选整整一年前的 1979 年 11 月 4 日。一共有 52 人。卡特自己把这变成了一个非常重大的议题，如果你根本无法把他们营救出来的话，这是一个相当愚蠢的做法。他派出了——好吧，他发起了一次营救他们的军事行动。是的，直升机。它们在沙漠中坠毁了。
of your state or whatever, then you will no longer be tax exempt. And this absolutely enrages a lot of the sort of churches that are behind these schools. It means they fall out terminally with Jimmy Carter. And Reagan has a brilliant way of reaching them. He goes to the religious round table in 1980,
这简直是一场绝对的灾难、混乱和悲剧。是的，我还记得一本新闻杂志上刊登的那些令人毛骨悚然的、在沙漠中扭曲的尸体和直升机残骸的照片。是的，还有那种普遍的感受：不仅是卡特的总统任期，整个美国都在急剧下滑，这显然为里根向人们兜售的一切提供了温床。绝对是的。关于成为“世界老二”的论调。因此，人们对里根最大的疑虑是：他是否过于极端？人们会不会在最后一刻依然坚持选择他们熟悉的卡特和他的开衫？里根在党代会之后正式发起了他的竞选活动——
this big meeting of all the sort of evangelical bigwigs. And he says to them, I know you can't endorse me, but I want you to know that i endorse you and what you're doing masterly and everyone's like hurrah what a tremendous fellow all this so yeah he wins the republican he's he's been hanging around in the 70s writing he's been on the radio i mean the reagan is a master of the radio if you ever read there's a book i think it's called reagan in his own hand or something like that, of all his radio scripts. He would have been a brilliant columnist. Well, he was a brilliant columnist. He wrote columns. He writes these five-minute scripts. They always
我曾说过我们会谈到这一点，因为这非常具有争议性。鲍勃·斯皮茨在他的传记中根本没有提到这一点，我真的不知道为什么。我想也许是因为它太具争议性了吧。里根在党代会结束后，在密西西比州一个叫尼肖巴县集市（Neshoba County Fair）的地方发起了他的竞选活动，台下有 15,000 名观众。这个地点非常、非常靠近 1964 年三名民权工作者被谋杀的地方。一个非常著名且悲惨的事件：詹姆斯·切尼、安德鲁·古德曼、迈克尔·施韦纳。他们在 1964 年被种族主义者杀害。里根去了这个地方，并发表了一场演讲，他在演讲中说：“我信仰州权。”现在，一些听众可能会说：“这有什么不对的？各州权力对阵联邦政府。”但在 60 和 70 年代的语境下，州权通常被视为一种隐晦的代名词，意思是：我不相信民权。我站在南方白人这一边。所以这是一个“狗哨”（暗示）。因此从那时起，人们就这场演讲是否属于狗哨引发了巨大的争端。
start with a little story. The other day I was in the supermarket and there was a man in front of me, a big strapping lad. He bought 72 bags of shopping. And then I couldn't help noticing that he paid for them with welfare stamps. And I said to myself, what am I doing wrong that this guy is on welfare and my taxes? Your tax dollars are going on. Yeah. Right. Margaret Thatcher would not, even though she was actually quite good at populism, she wasn't anything like as good as that. So he has this way of sucking people in. He wins the Republican nomination. He beats George. George Bush is his big rival. There's still a bit of
我认为这毫无疑问是一种试图吸引白人群体的尝试。引发了巨大的争端——我是说，关于这是否是狗哨，存在巨大的争端。我认为这毫无疑问是试图吸引白人、农村、南方的选民，他们中的许多人会把这理解为：我与你们站在一起，而不是站在黑人民权运动一边。所以对一些人来说——在当时，一些人绝对认为这是一个失言（外交或政治上的重大失误）。当时确实有人——试金石在于，他的民调专家理查德·沃思林曾对他说：“请不要这样做。这是一个巨大的错误。”但要在政治上取得成功，我想你必须具备一点唯利是图的政治手腕。还有另一些人对里根说：“卡特是个南方人。卡特在南方很有实力。你必须去那里，你必须做你必须做的事来赢得这些南方白人选民。”因为他最终赢得了 60% 的南方白人选票。这是他最终获胜的一个巨大因素。这投下一道阴影。
a doubt whether he is too right-wing. And that's Carter's big hope, actually, because Carter's presidency has basically descended into an utter abyss in 1980. The hostages are still in Iran. Killer rabbits
是的。所以笼罩在他头上的阴影就是这件事。我的意思是，这确实是一个巨大的阴影。是的。另一个阴影则是担心他过于好战。但他在辩论中非常漂亮地打消了这种担忧。所以这是他需要消除的另一个疑虑，即他是一个好战分子的恐惧。
are roaming the swamps of Florida. It's garbage. um well the economy is in recession uh his new head of the federal reserve man called paul volker he's a sort of monetarist his attitude is well we've got massive inflation so let's whack up interest rates so interest rates are heading towards 20 the soviet union have invaded afghanistan all the news is bad as far as carter is concerned the hostage is the worst of all. By far the worst. Because it's a kind of protracted, nightly on the news horror show.
他参加了辩论。时间很晚了，就在选举前一周左右。我想是 10 月 28 日对阵卡特。卡特曾在 76 年对阵杰拉尔德·福特的辩论中大获全胜。卡特严重低估了里根。他认为里根是个木偶、傻瓜、疯子，而且极度右翼。卡特非常自信。
And they were taken a year to the day before the 1980 presidential election on the 4th of November, 1979. There's 52 of them. And Carter himself makes it a really big issue, which is quite a foolish thing to do if you're not going to be able to get them out. And he sends, well, he does this mission to try and rescue them. Yeah, the helicopters. They crash in the desert.
卡特拥有成千上万册关于所有议题简报材料。他绝不会自降身段去读《读者文摘》。我的意思是，卡特是一个十足的控制狂。有传言说，卡特过去常常亲自处理白宫网球场的预约。你知道，卡特真的是个注重细节的人。所以他想：“我会把里根踩在脚下。”但实际上，他显得极具攻击性，而里根则非常迷人、
It's an absolute disaster, shambles and a disaster. Yeah, I remember a news magazine with the awful, the twisted bodies on the desert and the wreckage of the helicopters. Yeah. And the general sense that not just Carter's presidency, but America itself was on a massive downward slide, which obviously is playing into everything that Reagan is offering people. Absolutely. The thing about being number two in the world. So the big doubt about Reagan is, is he too extreme? Are people just going to stick with what they know with Carter and his cardigan at the last minute? And Reagan launches his campaign after the convention.
随和。卡特贬低他，里根只是说：“你又来了（There you go again）。”然后里根发表了一段极其精心雕琢的结辩陈词：“你现在的日子比四年前过得更好吗？你觉得我们现在的实力像四年前那样强大吗？”你根本无法给出肯定回答，因为卡特的总统任期简直是一场灾难。所以最后，那些数量众多的摇摆选民大规模地倒向了里根。他在选举人团投票中以 489 对 49 的悬殊比分获胜。对一位在任总统取得了一场压倒性的大胜。我一直认为，对里根成功的一个迷人小见解，发生在他获胜的那个时刻。
I said we'd get to this because it is very controversial. Bob Spitz doesn't mention this at all in his biography, and I don't really know why. I think maybe it's too controversial or something. Reagan launches his campaign after the convention at a place called the Neshoba County Fair in Mississippi in front of 15,000 people. And this is very, very close to the site
所以，我想是全国广播公司（NBC）率先宣布他胜选。他们宣布里根获胜，然后 NBC 的播音员——一个叫约翰·钱斯勒的家伙说：“因此，来自加州的罗纳德·威尔逊·里根，一个体育播音员、电影演员、加州州长，将成为下一任总统……”诸如此类。但那三个身份——体育播音员、电影演员，然后是加州背景，我的意思是，这些是核心。许多人总是说：“这个曾解说过想象中的棒球比赛、然后在所有这些糟糕电影里扮演男主角好友的家伙，怎么可能当上总统呢？”但实际上，正是因为他做过这些事。绝对是的。
where three civil rights workers were murdered in 1964. A very famous and tragic incident, James Cheney, Andrew Goodman, Michael Schwerner. So they were killed by racists in 1964. And Reagan goes to this place and he gives this speech in which he says, I believe in states' rights. Now, some listeners may say, well, what's wrong with that? States versus the federal government. But in the context of the 60s and 70s, states' rights is often taken as shorthand for, I don't believe in civil rights. I stand with the white South. So it's a dog whistle. So people ever since have had massive arguments about whether or not it's a dog whistle.
是的，还有通用电气。我的意思是，通用电气的经历影响巨大。难道最关键的事实不是：1980 年的美国对自身、对自己的前途、对世界的发展方向感到相当沮丧吗？而里根，不仅在他的个人魅力中，而且在他的个人背景中，看起来就像是美国最好一面的活生生的化身。他是美国梦的一种化身，而人们此刻的心情是不愿对此持怀疑态度的。是的。
I think it's undoubtedly an attempt to appeal to white had massive, I mean, the massive arguments about whether or not it's a dog whistle. I think it's undoubtedly an attempt to appeal to white, rural, southern voters, many of whom will take that as saying, I stand with you and not the sort of black civil rights movement. So for some people, so at the time, some people definitely see that as a gaffe. And there were people, I mean, the test is his pollster, Richard Worthlin, said to him, please don't do this. It's a big mistake. But to succeed in politics, you have to have a bit of cynicism, I suppose. And there are other people who are saying to Reagan, Carter is a Southerner. Carter could be strong in the South. You have to go there and you have to do what you have to do to win those white Southern votes. Because he ends up winning 60% of the white Southern vote. A big factor in his eventual victory. And this cast a shadow.
我认为这无疑是一种试图吸引白人群体的方式，我的意思是，关于这是否是含沙射影的暗号，存在着巨大的争论。我认为这毫无疑问是在试图吸引白人、农村、南方的选民，他们中的许多人会认为这是在说，我站在你们这边，而不是站在某种黑人民权运动一边。因此，对某些人来说，所以在当时，有些人绝对认为这是一个失言。而且有人——我的意思是，对他的考验是，他的民调专家理查德·沃瑟林对他说，请不要这样做。这是一个巨大的错误。但要在政治上成功，我想你必须有一点愤世嫉俗。还有其他人对里根说，卡特是个南方人。卡特在南方可能会很强。你必须去那里，你必须做你必须做的事来赢得那些南方白人的选票。因为他最终赢得了百分之六十的南方白人选票。这是他最终获胜的一个重要因素。这也投下了阴影。
Yeah. So the shadow over him is that. I mean, that's quite a shadow. Yeah. And the other one is the worry that he is too aggressive. But he dispels that quite nicely in the debate. So that's the other thing that he needs to dispel, the fear that he's a warmonger.
是的。所以笼罩在他头上的阴影就是那个。我的意思是，那真是一个巨大的阴影。是的。另一个则是担心他太好斗了。但在辩论中他很好地消除了这一点。所以这是他需要消除的另一件事，即人们对他是战争贩子的恐惧。
And he does the debate. It's very late. It's just a week or so before the election. I think it's the 28th of October against Carter. Carter had triumphed in the debates against Gerald Ford in 76. Carter completely underestimates Reagan. He thinks Reagan's a muppet, a fool, mad, really right wing. And Carter is very self-confident.
而且他参加了辩论。时间非常晚。就在选举前一周左右。我想那是10月28日对阵卡特。1976年卡特在与杰拉尔德·福特的辩论中大获全胜。卡特完全低估了里根。他认为里根是个木偶、傻瓜、疯子、真正的右翼。而且卡特非常自信。
Carter's got thousands and thousands of briefing books on all the issues. He never would sully himself with the Reader's Digest. I mean, Carter is such a control freak. Carter, the story goes that Carter used to handle their bookings to the White House tennis court personally. You know, Carter is really a detail man. So he thinks, I'll wipe the floor with Reagan. And actually, he's very aggressive and Reagan is charming,
卡特有成千上万关于所有议题简报册。他绝不会降低自己去读《读者文摘》。我的意思是，卡特是一个十足的控制狂。有传言说，卡特以前亲自处理白宫网球场的预约。你知道，卡特确实是个注重细节的人。所以他认为，我会把里根打得落花流水。但实际上，他极具攻击性，而里根则很迷人，
affable. Carter disses him. Reagan just says, there you go again. And then Reagan has this brilliantly crafted peroration. Are you better off than you were four years ago? Do you feel we're as strong as we were four years ago. And there's no way you can answer those questions and say yes, because the Carter presidency has been a bit of a disaster. So the last, all those undecided voters of whom there were many, they break massively for Reagan. And he wins in the Electoral College by 4.89 to 49. A huge landslide against a sitting president. What I always think is a fascinating little insight into Reagan's success is when he wins.
温和。卡特贬低他。里根只是说，你又来了。然后里根发表了一段精心雕琢的结束语。你们现在的日子比四年前好过吗？你们觉得我们现在有四年前那么强大吗？你根本无法回答这些问题并说“是”，因为卡特的总统任期有点像一场灾难。所以最后，所有那些数量庞大的摇摆选民，他们大量倒向里根。他在选举人团投票中以489票对49票获胜。对阵在任总统取得了一场压倒性的大胜。我一直认为，对里根成功的一个迷人的小见解是当他获胜的时候。
So it's NBC, I think, that puts him over the top. They declare that Reagan has won. And the NBC announcer, this guy called John Chancellor, he says, and so Ronald Wilson Reagan of California, a sports announcer, a film actor, a governor of California is to be the next president or whatever. But those three things, the sports announcer, the film actor, and then the California stuff, I mean, they're central. A lot of people always said, how is it possible that this guy who commentated on imaginary baseball games and then played the best friend in all these terrible films is president? But actually, it's because he did those things. Yeah, absolutely.
所以我想是全国广播公司宣布他胜出的。他们宣布里根获胜。全国广播公司的播音员，一个叫约翰·钱斯勒的人说，因此来自加利福尼亚的罗纳德·威尔逊·里根，一个体育播音员，一个电影演员，加利福尼亚州长，将成为下一任总统，诸如此类。但那三样东西，体育播音员、电影演员，然后是加州的事，我的意思是，它们是核心。很多人总是说，这个解说虚拟棒球比赛然后在所有这些糟糕的电影里扮演死党家伙怎么可能当上总统呢？但实际上，正是因为他做了那些事情。是的，绝对如此。
Yeah. And then the General Electric. I mean, the General Electric was massive. I mean, isn't the key fact that America in 1980 is quite depressed about itself, about its prospects, about the way the world is going. And Reagan, not just in his personality, but in his backstory, seems the living embodiment of the best of America. And he is a kind of embodiment of the American dream. And people are in a mood not to be cynical about that. Yeah.
是的。然后是通用电气。我的意思是，通用电气的影响太大了。我的意思是，关键事实难道不是1980年的美国对自身、对自己的前途、对世界的发展方向感到相当沮丧吗。而里根，不仅在他的性格中，而且在他的成长背景中，似乎成了美国最好一面的活生生的化身。他是美国梦的一种化身。人们正处于一种不对这种化身持讽刺态度的情绪中。是的。
And so they vote for him. Absolutely. And so his presidency is born. And that, ladies and gentlemen, will be the subject of our third and final episode on Ronald Reagan. And if you simply can't wait, you know what you've got to do. Yeah. Apple Podcasts. You just go to Apple Podcasts and sign up.
然后他们投票支持他。绝对是这样。于是他的总统任期诞生了。女士们先生们，这将是我们关于罗纳德·里根的第三集也是最后一集的主题。如果你实在等不及，你知道该怎么做。是的。Apple Podcasts。你只需要去 Apple Podcasts 订阅。
Or RestorsHistoryPod.com. That was Ronald Reagan there advertising the Restist History Club. Because he also advertised Chesterfields, didn't he, despite not smoking? He did. If he could advertise Chesterfields and General Electric, he could surely advertise the Restist History Club, couldn't he? You want to listen to this. It's going to be great.
或者 RestorsHistoryPod.com。刚才那是罗纳德·里根在为 Restist History Club 做广告。因为他也为切斯特菲尔德香烟做过广告，对吧，尽管他不抽烟？他确实做过。如果他能为切斯特菲尔德和通用电气做广告，他当然也能为 Restist History Club 做广告，不是吗？你们得听听这个。这会非常棒。
All about my presidency. No commies. They're all commies. Listen to us. Reassuring, homely, homespun wisdom from Dominic Sandbrook, the sage of middle England. Oh, God. Keep this stuff coming. I love it.
全关于我的总统任期。没有共产党。他们全都是共产党。听听我们说的。来自英格兰中部智者多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的安慰、质朴、带有家乡气息的智慧。哦，天哪。多来点这种内容。我太喜欢了。
All right. We will see you next time. Bye bye. God bless America. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
好了。我们下次见。拜拜。上帝保佑美利坚。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。要想收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并进入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。